32 vai jogar
[Música]
o ato só aqui quem fala mal da atitude
muito bem vindos à malha vermelha e
mostrados de que o vídeo não é o bom
sono que vai passar hoje aqui hoje nós
vamos ter
hoje nós vamos tentar acertar em alta e
uma cueca vão ser cumpridos assim o caso
alguém perto e para isso nós vamos lutar
com as nossas metas pois
[Música]
não sou basicamente nós vamos competir
um contra o outro e vamos tentar acertar
no alvo obviamente vai ter condições que
vamos ver agora e que não vai tirar
cinco vezes entre vermelhos pontuação
peru e qual é que vai ser a consequência
é maluco é que vai ser
vejam só que eu tenho aqui olha este que
é o líquido do eln e rick do rabo ou
seja isso cheira é cocó qualquer pessoa
mesmo com a romântica china muito mal eu
estudei muito e corre para analisar o
produto mesmo ao cordão humano olha aí
basicamente o que vai acontecer poderei
brasil vai levar com este guia de chance
tem de andar aqui o resto do dia mesmo
que podia todos têm a ganhar com este
ano atrás seja pronto socorro mas nem só
que eu perco então se eu fizer seis
casas impedir o shopping podem fazer
alguma coisa fora de casa eu vou te
contar as chances que tem o cheiro a
mofo quem perder vai usar cheira cola o
dito e ainda vai ter uma consequência
que um barco com este ano ocorre em
andar pela casa todas as casas para
então ser a copa vai ser patrão neves
temos tudo bem organizado não pode
driblar deus intervém china disputado
quadras não quiseram falar com cheiro a
copa também vocês têm que deixar lá vai
lá com cheira cola chan também é embora
lá e não só para este perfil tenha uma
lan house ou olha ai meu é muito bonita
e muito grande ela vai ser desculpa eu
entendi que este teste mas então eu
coloquei ela fica bem mais bonita e essa
desculpa que é muito bom porque ela dá
muita pontaria a lei dá muito jeito
porque ela dá para olhar aqui há muito
boa e uma ruim só mais um país foi muito
bom eu vou tentar acertar ali no jazz
rock 32 ou vai ou não vai
temos aqui uma mulher falta e fahel que
ela parece bastante pequena mas é muito
poderá afectar não só potente dela e vou
tentar acessar a linha já 32 vai o
quadro
você vai bem mais longe agora vai ter
dois ou um pai tem que ser mais próxima
ainda ok pessoal aqui tem o alvo então
muito sobre ela mas sem pontos
a posição mais um vai valer 50 pontos o
preço e 25 pontos
o branco vai ser respondida quanto fora
ou quem foi mas não algo mais ou menos
que 500 funk basicamente cada um vai ter
cinco a possibilidade de acionar o
alarme pois vamos fazer o cálculo em
meio ponto final 15
agora nós vamos ter que fazer uma
escolha senão vai julgar é quem ficou
foi mais fácil acertar tudo em cinco
oportunidades cara com estas têm oito
tentativas não mais pequenos na irlanda
é mais fácil salvar a sua letra coisa
que usar uma câmera nova portanto só
assistir sempre uma diferença no áudio
na qualidade da câmera eu estou só de
estar aqui inclusive porque porque está
havendo muitos casos já passaram e eu
não sei qual é o álbum que ela tá
cansado da câmera eo microfone não sai
maggi pr está bom
uma fita cola aqui embora eu acho que
está tudo 32 vai decidir os pontos a 10
pontos
é difícil convém ter um número médio 80
pontos 0 59%
a pjmr studio ir para lá três beijos no
uso mais duas tentativas para 21
a última tentativa para 2018 tentativa
de conseguir 295 pontos e agora quem é
bom vai ser muito bonita pois em mim é
vamos tentar aqui está no álbum vai ter
uma com o dar pra matou anotou 21 by one
[Música]
com uma tentativa já tem 100 pontos mais
quatro que o resultado é 24 saiu muito
mal do pai a 2 um pai que tenta
conseguir 21 vai ter 10 primeiros 30 não
consiga acertar no sangue para conseguir
sustentar sozinha o contrário
basicamente a mesma pontuação que o qual
eu não sei quem não chegou a encher a
roça coisa comigo
espero aqui muito tudo corre tira muita
coisa muito em cima de mim nas duas
línguas
i atenção é muito rico cheio mesmo muito
mal
agora vamos fazer é a bahia não tínhamos
muito mal não só vai fazer agora não vai
entrar em casa e vai entrar no 4 cada um
e vamos ver a criação de um segundo de
seus para o cheiro e para lá dentro do 4
1 e deixar faltar nada só entrou muito
mal na bola
há muito mal em casa branca neste ano
comenta e deixe eu posso lhe por que
vocês não deixaram lá e vocês vão tirar
a bola é bem melhor agora e agora vou
entrar na área pessoal